en este vídeo vamos a pensar en cómo
podemos usar nuestro conocimiento sobre
cómo multiplicar números de un solo
dígito para multiplicar números que
involucren dos dígitos así que por
ejemplo empecemos con cuánto es 5 por 18
puedes pausar el vídeo y ver cómo puedes
intentar aproximar esto y después lo
haremos juntos muy bien si nosotros
tratamos de resolver 5 por 18 una
estrategia puede ser decir oye es este
era la forma de expresar 18 como el
producto de dos números y lo primero que
se me ocurre es que 18 es lo mismo que 2
por 9 así que podemos reescribir 5 por
18 como 5 x y en vez de 18 podemos
escribir 2 por 9 ahora como nos ayuda
esto bueno que ahora en lugar de
multiplicar 2 por 9 primero para obtener
así 18 y después multiplicar por 5 lo
que podemos hacer es multiplicar primero
el 5 por el 2 y tal vez estés pensando
espera espera espera espera detente un
segundo antes hacíamos 2 por 9 primero y
ahora me estás diciendo que podemos
cambiar el orden vas a decir oye ahora
vamos a multiplicar 5 por 2 primero es
eso correcto la respuesta es simple es
si es correcto si multiplicas números de
un solo dígito puedes hacerlo en
cualquier orden que elijas a esto se le
conoce como la propiedad asociativa de
la multiplicación podemos asociar el 2
con el 9 primero podemos multiplicar los
primeros o podemos asociar el 5 con el 2
primero podemos multiplicar esos dos
primeros
ahora bien porque es útil bueno cuánto
es 5 por 2 eso es muy sencillo es igual
a 10 por lo tanto esto se da lo mismo
que 10 déjame ponerlo con el mismo color
10 por 9
ahora 10 por 9 es mucho más directo de
obtener para la mayoría de nosotros que
5 por 18 10 por 9 es 90 y ya está
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora queremos
resolver 3 por 21 pausa el vídeo y pepsi
puedes hacerlo por tu cuenta hay muchas
formas de resolver esta multiplicación
pero intenta ver si puedes solucionarlo
de la forma en la que resolvimos el
primer ejemplo bueno como puedes
imaginar queremos expresar 21 como la
multiplicación de dos números más
pequeños así que podemos escribir 21
como un 3 por 7 tal vez si escribimos 21
3 por 7 ahora podemos hacer primero tres
por tres déjame poner un paréntesis por
aquí y lo podemos hacer debido a la
propiedad asociativa de la
multiplicación que es una palabra
elegante para algo que esperamos sea
bastante intuitivo y entonces esto será
igual
bueno cuántos tres por tres esos nueve y
esto por siete que como ya sabemos es
igual a 63 bien hagamos otro ejemplo
porque esto es muy divertido imagina que
quieres obtener el resultado de 14 por
cinco pausa el vídeo y piensa si puedes
encontrar la respuesta
bueno una vez más podemos intentar
expresar el 14 como el producto de
números más pequeños 14 es 2 por 7 así
que podemos reescribir esto como 2 por 7
ó 7 por 2 y escribo 7 por 2 porque
quiero asociar el 2 con el 5 para
obtener 10 y esto por 5 y ahora puedo
multiplicar 2 por 5 primero y esto nos
dará 7 por 10 que por supuesto es 70 un
ejemplo más
queremos calcular 15 por 3 como lo
resuelves bueno podemos expresar 15 como
5 por 3 y después tendremos que
multiplicar este por 3
ahora bien podemos multiplicar primero
los 3 y el resultado de ello lo
tomaremos 5 meses entonces es 5 por 9 y
estoy seguro que estás familiarizado con
5 por 9 eso es igual a 45
otra forma de obtener 45 es decir oye 5
por 10 50 entonces cinco por nueve será
cinco menos que 50 lo que también es 45